hello dear Jess calm community of people
who like chess and play on chess calm
I'm going to show you my my favorite win
from the Tata Steel tournament in and I
can say and this is the game against
Levon Aronian from from round 5
unfortunately I cannot remember the game
anymore
so I have a computer by my side to help
me remember the moves that I have
forgotten they used to say that someone
who could not remember their games was
not a real chess player well I don't
know what I think about that so anyway
here we go
Aaron and I have played a lot of Queens
gambit both as whites and black against
each other and this is the Ruggles in
defense so I choose here the most quiet
continuation which is to chop off the
night block is C pawn as he has to put
the night here in order not to lose the
bishop and then to to play slowly and
let's see what I did next
remember what route 51
so this is an interesting kind of
position it seems that blacks should be
doing very well since you asked the
bishop pair and these pieces are
developed quite normally and I think
that black is is doing okay but it might
be easier to improve the white position
and it seems that in general black
should develop an initiative on the
Kings side since the bishop going to d6
will be pointing there and screen is
there and in in general it's easier for
black to generate something on the King
side but it's not so easy that's why it
is very solid
so I decided to return with the Queen
immediately and and to try and push me
forward to gain some space on the Queen
side and then eventually I can push the
maybe push the pawn to b5 then if it
takes I take with the night and I
threaten this spaceship in general it
would be very good to exchange this
bishop for for a knight since then there
would be absolutely no chances of black
creating an attack on on the Kings side
so it should be noted that LaVon tried
the same variation with with white
against against Anna in in baden-baden
about three weeks later and anon played
not quite in this position but in a very
similar position he played g5 put the
night and g6 move the Queen away and try
to push this F pawn which probably is
the the only real plan for black to do
something